i never asked y'all for anything
but i need your help with this
there's almost 7 million people that
follow me
somebody's got to know something
tick tock star ophelia nichols begs for
answers after her son randon lee was
fatally shot in alabama just one day
before his birthday today
would have been my baby child's 19th
birthday
[Music]
but he was took from me last night my
son was murdered
he was shot
and i had this
hatred
in my heart
that i don't recognize
because i
i've never felt hate
for anybody the social media star
affectionately known as mama taught to
her loyal fans called tater tots
announced the devastating news over the
weekend now ophelia wants help finding
the culprit and she's leaning on her
online community for all the times that
mama taught was there for us we have to
be there for her now to the person who
did this
you will be found while the homicide is
still under investigation ophelia shared
the tearful video with a message to her
son's murderer writing you may not be
caught now but it's coming i hope you
see my son's face every day of your life
and i want you to look at my son
look at my son
look at him
look at it
because i'll never say it again mama
todd has received an outpouring of
condolences and her eldest son gibson
shared a heartfelt tribute honoring his
little brother
[Music]
gibson writes fly high baby boy and adds
get your rest this one hurt me
as the family mourns randon's death the
mobile police department is continuing
their search you took from my childhood
and my husband and our family
this individual took my son's life
if she say 10 years old that's the best
part of somebody's life
i know they're out there
in my town
they're out there
they're out there
living and breathing
when my son is dead
[Music]
you